you might not realize this about me but
if you watch the show enough you do know
that I'm something of a culinary expert
and critic especially when it comes to
fast food and especially when it comes
to french fries uh I consider myself to
be um kind of a an afficionado of french
fries and I have said on the show many
times when it has come up that
Arby's has the best french fries uh
Arby's has the best french fries hands
down no question about it uh the worst
are McDonald's and McDonald's french
fries have actually gotten worse over
time it's not just but it's the best
fast food chain of all of them have you
lost your mind also has the best french
fries and so today I've been challenged
to uh rank french fries from a number of
major fast food chains without being
told who who what chain has produced
each individual fry um and I'll rank and
then I guess we'll see if I'm as good at
judging french fries as I think our
intern I'm told spent an hour and a half
going around buying french fries from uh
okay uh so we'll start here and we'll go
down the
list that's a solid french
fry very so it's
got It's got enough firmness which I
like
but um it's got the soft Center which
you need not
undercooked a little bit on the salty
side a little bit too much salt but
still pretty
good now see these are
[Music]
undercooked these are pretty offensive
to
me these are not just undercooked but
there's no seasoning this tastes like
it's like if you get a bag of frozen
french fries and you pull out of your
freezer you just throw them in the
oven and feed them to your kids cuz they
don't know what's good and what's
not those are very bad those are
terrible okay so these are an
Abomination this is this is a truly
disgraceful how do you not even put salt
there's no look at this there's no salt
on the on the french fries at all so
we've got like pretty
good uh a human rights violation see
what that looks
next also we got another salt problem
here we've got a salt problem and that
there's none
somehow a little bit undercooked you
know I have this Theory and I can't
prove it but I think the quality of
french fries Nationwide in really every
context has declined rapidly this is an
epidemic nobody's talking about but even
at at like a sit down restaurant french
fries just aren't what they used to be I
don't know what I don't know what that
is I don't know if they're getting the
potatoes from someplace different I
don't know I don't know how to explain
it but this uh is
another that's a poor showing that's bad
that's not good there no salt you can't
you got to season
it and if the french fries are properly
you notice something you notice what I
don't have when we're doing a french fry
T tasting I don't have ketchup I'm not a
child ketchup is for children and if
your French fries are properly seasoned
you shouldn't need ketchup you shouldn't
need any dipping sauce at all okay I got
news for you these two suck I would
still eat them all I mean don't get me
wrong if I went to a place and they gave
me this one oh my
[Music]
God like I'll eat the whole
thing but it's bad
there's a little more
salt still not okay here we've got we've
got the salt but the crispiness look at
this you see how that you see that how
it's kind of like it's flaccid I hate to
use that phrase for something I'm eating
but it is
like it just it's wilted you see that
that's not now like you see that there
that french fry yeah it's got some give
to it you know okay when you do that but
it's it's FM enough and you want that
firmness in your french fry and this is
just it's just hanging it's pathetic you
give this to me I'm going to throw it
back in your face so that's not good
we've only had one good one so
far and here I could already tell these
are barely these are like not cooked at
all this is not this is look at
this you said this wasn't even cooked
it's greasy so these were just doused in
grease they took it out of the freezer
they doused it in grease and they let it
just sit on a countertop and they're
serving it to me I don't even have to
eat look at that there's no look there's
all the grease there's plenty of Grease
there's no there's no salt there's no
seasoning and it's just it's just laying
there like that it's like a
[Music]
worm oh
no that that that's just that's pure
grease it just tastes like grease it's
congealed grease wow this this went
worse than I expected I didn't go into
this planning on hating all of them I
really didn't I I thought that you know
how could
this it's a YouTube video where I'm
eating french I don't know how enjoyable
the YouTube video is going to be for you
I thought it' be it would be enjoyable
for me but really this is the only this
is not perfect this is about an 85 I
give it about 85 points out of
100 this is about a 72 I give this about
a 72 maybe a 72.5 out of 100 um this is
a zero that that you get nothing and
then these two are right around the
50% not quite a passing grade
um uh this passes and this you know is a
good
D+ so that tells me I'm going to guess
that's uh number one that's our
Arby's so Arby's was number
two well I was pretty close then that's
not bad this was my second mess one
these are an Abomination truly
disgraceful I called it Abomination but
I you know what I don't even believe
this this is not this is not legitimate
this this is been rigged like you get
you told them to give me undercooked
fries don't you how do I know that you
didn't tell them oh I don't want salt on
the don't don't give me unsalted fries
there's no salt on these
fries this you found the one bad look I
know Arby's okay I've been Arby's all
over the country they found the one bad
Arby's location which is apparently
right near the studio and uh and they
managed to produce these subpar fries
but so Arby's you let me down